[Music]
welcome to another episode of i've got a
question i'm keith with little light
studios and today's question is this i
know my surroundings have an influence
on me but how do i know my thoughts are
my own and how can i distinguish between
impressions from god
well there are probably three buckets we
could put our thoughts into thoughts
from god
thoughts from the enemy
and our own thoughts which are
influenced by either of those two
sources
so which one are mine
well in one sense
they all are because you have the power
to choose which source of inspiration
you will adopt
but in another sense none of them are
because you're going to be inspired by
one of those two sources and so
those thoughts really didn't originate
with you in either case
so maybe the easier way to answer this
question is to determine from which
source the thought could come from
and we can do that with a couple of
principles in the bible
so this is what the bible tells us about
our own hearts
it says the heart is deceitful above all
things and desperately wicked
who can know it and you can find that
text in jeremiah 17 9.
so a good majority of the time we can't
trust our own thoughts because they lie
you know recently i read a book
about this last year with my wife and it
was called telling yourself the truth
it's amazing how many lies we actually
tell ourselves every day and where do
lies come from well the bible says you
are of your father the devil and the
desires of your father you want to do he
was a murderer from the beginning and
does not stand in the truth because
there is no truth in him when he speaks
a lie he speaks from his own resources
for he is a liar and the father of it
and you can find that text in john 8 44.
now
this does not have to mean that there's
a little devil whispering in your ear
if you get told something enough you'll
eventually believe it even if you
never hear it told again
in this way a lie can become part of our
own thoughts
but the great thing about all of this is
that we can recalibrate our own thoughts
with god's thoughts
the bible says it this way for my
thoughts are not your thoughts
nor are your ways my ways says the lord
for as the heavens are higher than the
earth
so are my ways higher
than your ways and my thoughts higher
than your thoughts
you can find that in isaiah 55 8-9
the bible also says this for i know the
thoughts that i think toward you says
the lord thoughts of peace and not of
evil to give you a future and a hope
that's in jeremiah 29 11.
you know we can find these thoughts in
the bible and reading them will
reinforce correct thinking and it gives
us a way to check our own thoughts and
determine is that one from the enemy or
one from god
but in all of this i hope you realize
the character of god god wants the very
best for you and he is doing everything
that he can to save you
destructive thoughts are from the enemy
but thoughts that promote life and
health
those are from god
the bible puts it this way
the thief does not come except to steal
and to kill and to destroy
but i have come that they may have life
and that they may have it more
abundantly
don't hesitate to reach out to us with
more questions you can put those in the
comments below on social media or you
can contact us through our website
and we will see you next time
[Music]
so
you